♫ Take you to the movies
♫ Girl, we'll make the movie
♫ How I fallin' back to the beat
♫ I'm on a roll
♫ Take on the world
♫ Yes, yes, y'all
- [Sam] I work with Zulu P,
and they are a rap group
here in New York City.
They've played shows all
over New York at this point.
The group consists of the
founding member Marley G.
- I'm the great Marley G.
- [Sam] Sweetness.
♫ Like a sunshine
- [Sam] T. Rock.
♫ My microphone chill
♫ Might overload it
- [Sam] And Lil E.B.
- All better and peace!
They have a really
original take on hip-hop.
We have a program here that serves adults
with developmental disabilities
who also play music.
They don't seem to develop preconceptions
about how things should be.
Definitely musically.
It's a really striking
kind of freedom, I think,
for people who live their
lives guided by and sometimes
bounded by other people's
perceptions or preconceptions.
(deep beat)
- [Sam] We just book Zulu P on shows
like you would book any regular band
and don't give any type
of preface or anything.
People will come.
They'll see the show,
but you can see that there's
a little tension there
for people.
But I think it's a productive
and interesting tension.
(audience applauds)
The members of Zulu P are completely open,
totally positive, always down.
They're not cynical, and
they're never self-conscious.
- I'm Zulu P.
Peace out.
- [Sam] It's really amazing to see them
get up there and crush a show.